[Music]
[Applause]
hey when I started this that's a 40 oh
it's a Brian Conan O'Brien I'm him
the comedian TV host doing a big show in
[Applause]
we have a new policy Americans are
subject to extreme very extreme the
vetting you might just be one of those
bad hombres I see what you're doing all
right we got some new people running the
United States and that's created some
tension between our countries
you can't lump all Americans into one
group it's not fair
stereotyping gracias thank you so much
I wasn't sure if you guys would have
good food steak they're like 15 years
ago
okay and I stole the towel and I'll just
see myself blue the border this is a
great
I fly by of course everybody welcome to
the cotan made in Mexico a lot QA that's
right I know I know what you're about to
say go ahead say it
you're way too loud you might yell
during these things when blaze sends
emails to any of us he uses at least 35
exclamation points it's actually true
and that's also the way you talk that's
all hey gang I'm trying to get you to
talk in a natural voice everyone can
hear you and it's fine welcome to the
live Q&A
you still know Bill - no creepy you show
to vote YouTube Facebook and Twitter
Facebook Twitter salute you we are here
with Conan O'Brien obviously uh he has
to be called caterer Mike Sweeney but in
charge of the whole thing
writer Jesse gasps co-producer Frank
smiley and all of these people
instrumental in putting together the
conan made in mexico show which you saw
last night i'm sure on TBS or you can
watch now Team Coco Coco calm if you
missed it okay this is the show we're
proud of stuff of all of our travel
shows so yeah maybe your grandmother
watched it on linear way you get to
watch it on digital anytime you like you
know while you and your pals are free
Basin you can be watching this that's
digital is that true Jesse yeah well I'm
sure they are and if you go to Tim
koco.com slash Mexico you can see the
show as well as a whole bunch of other
stuff that actually didn't make the show
including outtakes
uncut remotes of which we're gonna watch
one of those at 11:30 gifts and behind
the scenes oh well let's start with the
gift that keeps well done Jesse he
couldn't be with us today because he's
off writing something for tonight's show
that will be cut
Jose Arroyo instrumental in the entire
process also a great writer on the show
Jose and Jesse have been involved in
every single travel show we've done and
they're remarkable writers Mike Sweeney
just so
I reiterate again he's the guy who
tirelessly researches these shows and
edits and they wouldn't happen without
Mike Sweeney Frank smiley he could live
or die doesn't matter you know Frank for
the very beginning was very passionate
about this project and and jumped in and
was a huge force of nature and helping
out and blared without you we wouldn't
have had all those exclamation points on
your different tweets happy to help
yeah so the last time we we spoke on the
live Q&A we just gotten back from Berlin
and a lot of people asked where are you
going next right the answer was Mexico
why did you choose Mexico Mexico because
clearly so much in the news and this was
sort of a response to at the time there
was a lot of press about the rocky
relationship between the new
administration because of the campaign
rhetoric building the wall and and and
the Mexican people and we just wanted to
go down there and find out what was
going on and just try and make them
laugh
I mean basically that's the the the
mission on these shows is to go to these
other countries and and just make them
laugh if we can and make friends and you
know not be too strident not be too you
know getting into the issues because
there's so little you know we can do
about that and it feels like everyone if
you go on Twitter everyone's yelling
back and forth at each other we try and
in some way cut around that and just go
places and let them laugh and if it that
that means laughing at me and I'm the
gringo pinata then fine but let's hear
how they what they have to say let's do
comedy with them and the Mexican people
were an absolute joy they're great
improvisers they're really funny
everybody we ran into I mean we had a
hard time
everyone was great everyone's great and
they had a hard time cutting we shot so
much stuff that to get it into one hour
was next to impossible I can't believe
we did it there's so much extra because
as improv partners I don't know if
there's anybody better than Mexico City
there they're hilarious and funny and
they get
and when I was out there with the bank
you know saying let's raise money for
the wall yeah they got it right away
they understood what I was doing and
they were fantastic yeah absolutely and
I think one of the what you spoke to one
of the greatest things about this
particular show is the balance it
strikes between kind of a serious
message and also really hilarious
remotes I mean the Lucha Libre thing is
absolutely fantastic when you've gotten
the ring and did a little Mexican
wrestling Mike how when you at this
moment
Conan's like we're gonna go to Mexico
what is what are kind of the first steps
how do you get your arms around an
entire country I learned where Mexico is
okay perfect itself yes I think Jesse
came up with the crazy rooster character
I did in Scott chronic the custom oh my
god he's an amazing costume designer who
will give him ID like you just give him
that yeah I want to give in the world of
costumes I want to give Frank a quick
piece of credit when it and I think
we're gonna see this later on when I
play soccer yes a football
I'm sorry footballs or an exit soccer if
you're in United States and don't care
about something but Frank immediately
said and this is how Frank talks you'll
see but he talks like I got an idea no
but Frank came kicking down my door and
he said you're gonna play
you're gonna play soccer see and he
talks like he's trying to sell you a
newspaper in 1928 he's like you gotta
buy this paper there's a big story about
whoever and he said you're gonna play
soccer he said and the shorts have to be
way too short Smith you look like an
idiot and as Scott cronic the costume
guy has learned and Frank instinctively
knows I have the longest legs in the
world
and they're also incredibly pale and
skinny so if you can heighten that by
putting the in pretty much a bikini
bottom
people start laughing and so good work
Frank yes it's called cheating
I think your people got a pair for
people haven't seen the episode yet to
whet your appetite we do have a picture
of the Lucha Libre costume which we're
gonna show right now yeah so you haven't
eaten oh look at how pale it really
highlights the the chest up there yeah
there was no no attempt to put make up
my body for that removed just so people
could see what my wife endure is every
evening this is hard to tell your second
no it stops the costume picks up it
really looks it looks like an albino
seal that's been dead for too late hood
washed up on shore exactly what no Tracy
from YouTube asks what did you love
about making a telenovela so there's
that something else you've done and and
a theme by the way for all the travel
shows my if all I could do for the rest
of my life would be to appear in soap
operas in the countries in a serious
role and I didn't get paid a dime and it
actually cost me money and I had to
donate blood constantly to do it I would
in a second take that deal is my
favorite thing to do I've appeared now
in soap operas in Armenia South Korea
Mexico Berlin Berlin and I I just love
it and this was my favorite one because
they gave me a chance to we seriously
did ask them for a romantic scene and
they seriously said now we don't see you
in that situation and then they came
back and they said you're a Mennonite
cheese merchant no joke and so I played
it straight and I really did keep
forgetting my hat and they I mean you
got to watch that please watch that
because it's my chance to and the
craziest thing is they have this
beautiful absolutely one of most
beautiful women I've ever seen is in the
telling of and at one point I'm angry
that she's not gonna buy my that I'm
being trifled with and they have no
cheese to sell so I'm about to leave and
she puts her hand on my arm and there's
a close-up and I look at her and it may
cut to her
she's been struck by a bolt of lightning
if you saw this girl and you saw me it
is the most absurd moment in the history
of dramatic acting that she would feel
anything this big creep and a fake
mustache I thought she was just smelling
cheese yeah yeah she might she might be
but anyway that that made me so happy
and and and good god they didn't they
say they bring you back yes they said
they bring me back and you know what if
they bring my character back I will
donate I will do everything I have to do
I will fly down on my own I'll take a
bus whatever I have to do I will get
there and I will play that part I'm just
it's my obsession now that's awesome
yeah Irwin actually from Facebook just
said his favorite part with you
forgetting the Hat of the tell ya every
time he's dying yeah Jesse Weezy from
twitch asks do you think Weezy from The
Jeffersons is on twitch currently and I
do you think different kind of jokes
work for different cultures did you find
that there was any kind of joke gap and
and when when we went there and you were
speaking to Mexican people well we were
wondering that I mean I think especially
with that the bit where Conan is asking
people on the street to donate to the
wall and he's offering them a brick yes
you know we're trying out his monologue
jokes on the people yeah I think we were
concerned is this something that's gonna
be funny to us as sort of an outsider
but is this gonna translate and people
were we were amazed by the by how
quickly people caught on the guy that I
mean they were smiling and saying no not
giving you anything and then doing funny
things and some of them had a very
positive message that there's that
couple that says you should put love
into the butt you know and they they had
a very very elevator that way
immediately immediately there was not we
were not confronted with anger we were
confronted with relief there were a lot
of people that were just happy that we
were there and we were putting the
camera on them and letting them speak
and
I think it was also nice and it's a
common theme in these shows is that I'm
the immigrant I'm the outsider
absolutely so I don't belong you know
and I look at whenever I'm in these
other countries whether it's in Korea or
Mexico or Armenia I look different I'm
not part of the culture I'm trying to
participate and usually failing and they
laugh at me and they understand I think
that's that's where it's a good fit is
that you know the the style of comedy I
think being kind of self-deprecating
works in these other countries because
they pretty quickly pick up on the fact
that oh this guy doesn't have the status
they have the status that's kind of I
think the underlying tone which is nice
they get to refuse me yes I'm begging
for money and they're in the power
position of you know old ladies young
kids dogs they're all like no screw you
get out of here which i think is really
nice that's true and some of my favorite
moments where we're from old ladies in
this in this show where one of the old
ladies is laughing at you hysterically
or again when you were trying to get
money to pay for the wall and she's just
yeah she gave that beautiful speech that
my yeah I didn't know what she was
saying until you speak español but until
it was subtitle I said wow wow that was
you know then test everyone we asked
they would turn to camera and there's
the occasional person that would just
say you know F a certain you know world
leader fine to be named later yeah but
but most of them did not lead with anger
they led with us hey we're all one
people this is a misunderstanding we're
you know it was and they gave these
beautiful talks and I'm talking about
22 year olds and 82 year olds and that
was the part that made me happiest was
that we were confronted not with
negativity not with skepticism but with
so much good feeling yeah absolutely
a frank this is your first travel show
you were on you
and you you did a lot of great producing
internet including chef aquiles Shabbos
right yes what was it what it's what
surprised you about a taking the show on
the road with Conan and how hard was it
to produce something when you weren't
there and then having to immediately
because we did a whole show we did two
shows studio shows when we were there
what were the challenges you found uh
basically I just felt that there was so
much going on it was like running on a
treadmill the whole time yeah that at a
certain point I hit a pace and I just
didn't feel it I just was in automatic
and Shabbos was a professional I
couldn't believe how he produced me and
we need to get him on the show here in
LA
immediately he is a fent he's the best
chef was like the best cooking segment
he got in a while
yeah he was in he it was a perfect
chemistry between Chavez so that guy
should be a regular here in Burbank but
no III didn't even come up for air until
just recently in the studio and and I
actually worked better that way like
where I don't have time to think right
just what was really impressive is and
this is true of Mike Sweeney and Frank
smiley is that there was very little
time to edit and I think restrictions
sometimes bring out the best I mean
there was we shop yet we shot the
remotes in Mexico City and then had to
turn around and air them in the studio
because we were doing the actual taping
of the show and we wanted to roll those
in for that audience and yeah the first
time we'd ever had to do and we had to
do it very fast and I've we shot so much
stuff I thought were just screwed
there's no way we're gonna get this all
together and and Sweeney and and Frank
smiley both immediately like we'd shoot
the thing and they would disappear and
stay in an edit room for 24 hours and
say okay I've got it down to this and
then I would look at Anna going yeah you
pretty much got yeah everything we
needed
so and
yes yes not a third rider matter Brian
came down Madame Ryan the head right I
came down yeah can I say one thing Jones
that added to the that relates to what
Frank was saying Frank was saying how he
just you know was such a blur you have
to understand that at one moment were in
a soccer field a football field and
we're with all these people and we bring
out geo and the place goes crazy and
kids are running from all over the
neighborhood and it's this huge
happening and then the next minute the
next thing I know it's late at night and
Frank and I I'm in a white tuxedo and
Frank's in a suit with a tie and we're
in a quinceanera for this beautiful
young girl Marysol and we were like
sparklers are going off and they were
dance numbers and Frank and I remembered
at one point are sitting in chairs next
to each other
and we're part of a quinceanera in
Mexico City and both of us it is like
putting on a VR helmet absolutely no
you're not web savvy but that's virtual
reality but when you but it wasn't
putting on a VR helmet where they just
keep changing the environment constantly
so it's you're at a telenovela you're at
a quinceañera you're here they're there
you're on the street you're an arrest in
the end I don't know I thought that - I
find that to be if you want to know what
these travel shows are like put on a VR
helmet but have it changed games
completely every 30 seconds absolutely
and I love those lines a colic from
twitch asks was there anything in Mexico
that you guys wanted to do that we
didn't was there anything kind of on the
board before we went that we just kind
of could I bet you Franklin's
frustrating thing for me is being in a
van going from place to place to going
the Anthropology course well I made it
to the Trotsky Museum
I know that's a big question for
everybody I got my little Trotsky
medallion right here so many questions
you all know about Trotsky but anyway I
made it to Trotsky's house but I
desperately wanted to go to the frida
kahlo museum and we actually went to it
and the entire museum came out and took
selfies with me and then I said hey can
I just come in and look for like 30
seconds and they went no ticket and you
need to get to the and there was a line
that was and we're closing in ten
minutes so Noah and I thought I never
asked for VIP treatment ever ever ever
ever but I said wait a minute
I took selfies with everyone in line
hundreds of people out of museums with
the security guards and then the people
that run the museum came out and took
selfies with me and then I went could I
just take a quick peek and they were
like no you will obey the rules so they
shut me down hard but I'll get back
there what were what were some of your
favorite moments that maybe didn't make
it on the air any any moments we did a
lot of Facebook live which was great you
can go to our Facebook page
and see a lot of large chunks of us just
hanging out which is fantastic but
anything that kind of that didn't that
we just didn't shoot they just hang I
was I mean the quinceanera for me was
such a yes such a cool experience
I I'm so mad at my parents I didn't get
one time it was this whole I mean
there's a whole performance involved
with it it's not only does the girl put
on the beautiful dress but then she
performed in all of these dance numbers
that were choreographed with her friend
that was there was fireworks inside her
father told me that she spent three
months working on all these Michael
Jackson songs different numbers and and
she and she has all these guy friends
and they all did all these incredibly
complicated synchronized dances kind of
like a Super Bowl performance yeah it's
just really what it was touching three
months on my haftorah yeah much rather
than worth that
yes I remember spending puberty alone in
my room in the Catholic faith there's
not a lot of yeah there's a lot of shut
up you're not to talk about sir like I
said before you could see a whole bunch
of great stuff that didn't make the show
Team Coco calm / Mexico and one of those
things that we had to slice down to fit
into the hour of conan made in mexico
that aired last night was this great
remote that frank produced with Giotto
Santos
Giovanni Giovanni Giovanni dos Santos
thank you and we're gonna watch the
uncut remote right now so sit back and
enjoy some very short shorts well it's a
Sunday and I'm at Parque Pilates this is
a popular place for people to get
together and play pickup games next can
spread themselves on being the very best
at football
well this gringos here to school them
arrived and unknown and leave a legend
how are you gonna say I'm fine how are
you do you have any questions for me
about my abilities yeah well I played
once in summer camp 1974 okay well
relatively you know if you're thinking
about geological history no pretty
recent have you ever keep something I
did I I kicked an old man once
is he okay oh he beat the up
[Music]
ha
I did it
I can't went to the mall we do have one
question do you have oxygen in the tank
guys I feel guilty I don't feel like I'm
helping the team as much as I should we
know that you know it's posible can I
please go and get a friend to help our
team is that okay I'll be right back
stay right here he plays a little bit of
football
[Applause]
yes right what's the plan you want me to
do
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
what did you learn from me today when
playing football yeah what skills you
saw some of my tricks what did you just
what did you learn I think your first
touch great touch my first touch is
great an agile like a cat yeah gato you
brought so much joy today here everyone
who plays thank you so much thank you I
have a usually Mexican Jersey for you I
wear this I will wear this and I will
play on your team do you want that
perfect back and just a reminder the
best questions that you guys have today
will win some great swag including this
amazing signed poster by Gio and Conan
there we go through that picture because
it's really I want to say Lou Mary Carey
Mary great job with this poster and some
other great sign Conan swag will be
yours so keep those great questions
coming and where was that part close-up
working Pilate market Pilate that's the
city that's right that's kind of a great
well-known spot where they have pickup
games yeah football and the the the
young man who was the captain of my team
who was sort of took the lead and spoke
you know excellent English he was
explained to me that that's a part
that's traditionally been free yeah and
now I don't know it's the city officials
are thinking of maybe making charging
people to use that power so we said that
we would do our part to kind of and they
had me sign a petition um to oppose that
but we're gonna look into at least we
said we'd like to look into is there any
way we can help with the movement to
keep that Park free because it's
obviously such a cool place forever
let me just say when Gio came out and
you saw the reaction yeah of those
people that almost I I'm devoid of
emotions
I lost my emotional center of my brain
an accident a long time ago but I
practically start to cry when I see
those young men respond to Gio coming
it's their dream come true and then you
start to see in the background kids
running from other parts of the park and
very quickly such a giant mob form that
we couldn't even film the remote it was
a lot of work to extract them so that we
could get back to the business because
instantaneous instantaneous just it's
like if I showed up at flappers comarcas
they're every happy hit people Ukraine
flappers what's uh via that was really
cool because it made I mean they'll be
telling their grandkids about that and
that goalie really took it oh my god you
say Frank's idea that's a good angle geo
scores a goal obviously very quickly and
then Frank comes running out we're all
thinking we got it that's the end and
frankly no the end should be I'm telling
you I'm telling ya and he's got like a
big pastrami on rye how he got that in
Mexico City I don't know he's got a
cigar bowler no it's got to end with
Conan getting a goal and I'm like what
how am I gonna get a go anyway don't
worry we'll put the fix in the saddest
goal ever I didn't want to do it but
Frank's Franco his whole career has been
making me do things and Frank wait you
gotta do it it's the ending so a a
tortoise has kicked a soccer ball harder
than I did and that poor goalie who's
really amazing was told by Frank you
know you're gonna let this one fruit
cease so the goalie doesn't he kind of
moves towards the ball then suddenly
he's got like sickle-cell anemia
just collapses you know the lamest thing
and you made it happen and then you put
a thing in that says Conan is lames made
me do something lame and then you enroll
Conan's lame
I know one of what what are the other
great moments with Frank and Conan I
think was the Lucha Libre remote where
Conan is in this giant get up and and
work Frank I think you were trying to
get have Conan do more physical stuff
but Conan is not an actual wrestler in
real life and so you wouldn't and we're
at altitude it's a 6,500 feet and I'm
not sleeping like because we're working
all the time and I'm Jeff Ross and so I
love Jeff Ross is on the sidelines and
Jeff's main role is to always say like I
wouldn't do it do it I wouldn't do it I
wouldn't get on that horse do this I'm
gonna do that I wouldn't tell a joke it
might not work go home right now and and
Frank keeps so the so the luchador
Sandro was trying to get me to get up
stand on the top rung do it somersault
31 do a somersault and like land like
tuck my head in and if I do it just
right I won't be paralyzed one of those
wires had just broken right before you
arrived on the ring about half an hour
it was a disaster I mean we showed up in
the electricity was down yeah Cassandra
said he was gonna take me to have to get
made up and then the ropes broke the
best part of that remote is in my
opinion if it was talking about
something that was not seen there was a
tiny little men's room where we changed
so I changed into my eye
I changed into my costume and II changed
into his costume I'm dressed like a
giant half-naked rooster Andy's dressed
like a giant baby we're in this tiny hot
locker room and we're standing there and
they're not ready for us so Andy and I
are just standing there I think in there
for about 40 minutes well these guys are
futzing around trying to figure
something out and at one point I just
turned and there was a mirror and I
saw myself on this costume and I thought
about my age the fact that I have
children how long and I just had this
great moment of like leaving my body
thinking why why is Wyatt Wyatt
what an absurd life I wasn't sad it was
part of me was like yep at least you
weren't alone in there no I have the
shame reminded me of the end of requiem
for a heavyweight
mary-elizabeth the faceplate ass who
came up with andis baby costume was that
you Jesse that was Annie immediately oh
well let's talk quickly about that you
know the remotes are only one half of
Mexico the other half was the studio
show with Diego Luna President Vicente
Fox
Kelly Kelly brave 50 as well as a
monologue and espanol a monologue in
espanol and the chef Chavez and also a
stand-up Sophia Nino de Rivera which was
she's very good very good I just sat out
to her she's a very good stand-up and
she was on the show and we just couldn't
get everything in the program but I
think her set is young line absolutely
have to check her out she's really funny
and I was laughing I would I couldn't I
speak some Spanish and so she was
speaking quickly but I could kind of
understand what she was saying and I
thought her set was really funny and
then later on I had other things
explained to me but just her physicality
was very funny she says she's very good
absolutely and so and and what was it
like did talk about odd about Auto Body
experiences what was it like being on in
this Mexican set doing a studio show I
mean I know you worked really hard on
your on your monologue was it that
different from being here it was because
we had a whole Mexican crew and all
these other p.m. first of all we cannot
say enough good about the crew
Televisa they were fantastic the
director Lalo the executive producer and
then these kemon yeah they did such an
incredible job they made it so easy for
us the audience was fantastic so we
didn't know what to expect
walked out there there was so much
goodwill they tolerated my my attempts
at EDD at Spanish yeah and I was very
pleasantly surprised that we do this
show day in and day out and we've been
doing some version of this since 1993
yeah and so sometimes when you change it
up completely and you're in another
country on another set speaking a
different language it's so invigorating
people think well that would that be
hard it's liberating it's really yeah
life giving it makes you it gives you
all this new energy that at this stage
of the game in this stage of my career
to have an experience like that makes
you feel like you're 25 and starting out
again it was really fun
that's cool I'm vinegar stroked from
twitch I'm sorry I have to say these
names
that's how did the mezcal Diego Luna
gave you taste I'm okay with mezcal yeah
I love I don't know how you guys felt I
was more I was more drawn to the tequila
and maybe probably some of the smoother
tequila's than I am to mezcal and also
I'll be honest with you I'm not mister
I'm not a great aficionado of hard
liquors like I'm mostly like a wine guy
I'm pretty square I'm not someone who's
like oh I love this whiskey you know and
I but I really do love a good tequila
and we had some amazing tequila down
there yes which was fantastic and the
food is absolutely incredible yeah did
you guys how a lot of people are asking
how spicy Team Coco went do you guys you
guys need anything super spicy or
anything that you just absolutely love
down there one night we were editing and
the only restaurant that was open was
Burger King was the last night the first
night the first night our security guy
James who was great took us to this
fantastic taco place which actually
what's it called Johnson
it was Levi's Khalifa which I was great
you actually went back to him Jorge
Ramos I went I did an interview with
Jorge Ramos yeah amazing journalist
terrific interviewer and he did kind of
a man on the street yeah the spiciest
thing I had is he took me to Khalifa and
there's he was recommending one of the
least talked of the sauces or medium
there may be six there six there and I
went right to DEFCON I was like I want
this one because one every one camera
I'll do anything I'm on camera I wanted
so I put a lot of it on ate it and yeah
it it dissolved my pancreas
this is actually this is kind of
speaking of dangerous things that you'll
do on camera I tell the river 85 asked
from twitch asked on the cold open did
the dog jump on Conan and I hope no
biting was involved Sweeney you wanna
answer that push the photos no I didn't
post it oh okay I didn't go public with
it oh maybe I did no setup is that we
had a bunch of fine takes for the trophy
it's very hot in space and then the
drone goes up for two hours out into the
desert it's a big shoot they don't have
a lot of great shots yes someone asked
for one more take was it you or was it
Matt it was Sweeney said we need one
more and you said it would be really
good if the dog got closer the problem
is that the dog was coming out to it yes
the problem is that the person who
trained the dog said it is an attack dog
it will stop them it's trained it'll
stop the minute you stop so when the dog
gets close
stop and then of course the comedy
writers said it's funnier if you keep
going in dog gets you a new express
concerns you're like I in the last run I
I felt like if I keep running it's going
to attack me yes so I keep running they
said keep running so like an idiot
to take you see I think is the last take
I run at the very end you see the dog
jump I'm running and I'm just about to
stop but I let the dog catch up to me
and I didn't stop the jog the dog jumps
up I'm wearing a suit and I feel a
shooting pain right here and I know it's
right here because I can still feel he
large clotted wounds it's claw from its
paw went through my suit and punctured
the skin and then I start limping back
and I can see everyone coming towards me
and then I see that there is a big hole
and I pull up my suit and there's blood
it's running all the way down my leg and
so they come and they have like bactine
whatever the stuff you have in a camping
trip and anyway over the next day I bled
through like four band-aids just kept
every time you learn a place with bleed
through and then this massive bruise but
my law and then my my wife sees me like
step out of the shower and she's like
what the hell happened I said oh they
used an attack dog what and I'm always
coming home with something messed up and
she's always saying what happened and I
said well we were doing something that
involved a falcon holding a razor blade
so I still have you know you can see it
but if I can't get my legs high enough
but I still have a healthy I don't show
it's it's actually we actually have a
shot of it in the cold open BTS on the
web so you can see how it all went out
which is you wanted an action
in the cold day there's also footage of
me rubbing Alpo on your the dog it
wasn't the dog's fault dog was a Belgian
Shepherd yeah great dog really fantastic
beautiful dog really well trained and he
does a great take in the cold open where
I'm explaining Who I am the dogs like
yeah I also loves the dog can read when
I hold up the Trump Tower
the dogs familiar with Trump's real
estate it was kind of funny when we did
the football remote I remember they had
to put some extra makeup on the in your
inner thigh that's how high the shorts
were because did you guys did anybody
bring back any souvenirs I know you have
your Trotsky medal Frank did you bring
back any souvenirs from Mexico a bunch
of crap for my kids I went to the
airport you didn't have time to stop I
was supposed to bring back to wrestling
masks for each one of my kids and I
never got a chance so at the last second
at the airport I got tchotchkes in there
they were happy so where's very this is
a common theme on these trips yeah
people say what did you bring home for
your family we we work up until the last
second absolutely and then the minute
we're done with the taping there's it's
nighttime and then we get up in the
morning and you Jam all of your stuff
you've been living out of you're into
suitcases yeah and your costumes and
your weird shorts and your wrestling
masks you Jam them into these suitcases
and you run and you get in the van and
you get to the airport and but and then
you rush to the gate and then you're in
Los Angeles you know like what about
your shopping trip it's like there's no
time yeah I might do i how do I get it
clear just right yeah that camera right
there look at that is leon trotsky right
there good this well you see Trotsky
who's Trotsky versus Stalin who won that
one
and screw with Stalin positive it's the
boot he goes to Mexico Solomon says kill
them they get him with an icepick
1840 but you knew that yeah people
always wonder what it's like to be in
these trips and I do remember a distinct
mode where Conan gave us all like a
20-minute lecture of Trotsky getting
stabbed in the head with a nice big on
the way from definitely another it was
just exactly it's important to me that
we make these shows but also that I get
a chance to babble about history
actually one thing for people that
didn't actually make the show or really
any behind the scenes was that Bieber
was staying in our hotel just Justin
Bieber and so every time we would pull
in there'd be just screaming girls and
they would all think that we never
recovered they were there yeah yeah
yes there actually to be fair there'd be
like eight hundred screaming girls for
Bieber and then two girls for me wanted
to talk about Trotter bull exasperated
the dental emergency oh that's after the
wrestling yeah we go out to dinner after
the wrestling just I literally bite into
a piece of bread and I'm sitting next to
Andy talking to him Alison they feel
something and I reach into my mouth and
I pull out a tooth and it was just the
cap and crown but was in the back tooth
and it popped off I think during the
wrestling people are horrified okay yeah
Andy said man I hope it's your tooth and
then we were picturing the waiter coming
out and saying how's your meal and
smiling and hissing a big
I preach you the bread but what happened
was I wouldn't I wouldn't pay attention
to it except that with the cap off
there's just nerve so when I would take
a sip of even lukewarm water it was like
a pain that went right up through my
head so I knew I had to get this thing
pop back on
fortunately Jeff Ross knows everybody in
any City we're in Jeff is hooked up with
some people had some friends that night
who I ran into I see Jeff and I was like
oh my tooth popped out here's like I got
my friends here guys what are we doing
they're like you know you go to this
doctor he's the best doc he's the best
dentist in in Mexico City here's his
number we'll set it up we'll drive you
over there so they these people took
wonderful care of me that's awesome and
the dentist was amazing I he was he's
great as dental his office was had this
great view of Mexico City he was really
funny and he put some glue in that thing
and snapped it right back on and we
could have any feathers yeah Eric from
YouTube asked would you can we get you
on Wrestlemania would you go on
WrestleMania go on as the rooster cross
over if I could go on with Andy as that
you know and I could go and represent
Mexico yeah now I'm sure Mexico does not
want us representing them in any
capacity but I'm just saying the offers
there right that would be more
interesting to me as a as a as a way to
bring our two nations closer together I
think Andy and I should go as mime
senora's now would be unbelievable we've
got a scene first
what's that would you say it makes
things worse we're almost out of time so
get your last questions in and and I
think we will just start kind of the
final questions the question we get the
most when we do this live Q&A is where
are you going next and I think we don't
really know but I'll start with Frank
where would you like to see us go gosh
well the obvious one is Jordan in Italy
that's an obvious one
magical but also I know we you in Conan
did a little remote in Ireland I think
that would be great
back is late-night yeah Ireland be
explore Irene I hope Trump attacks the
Seychelle Islands excuse to spend a week
there beautiful beaches those people
yeah at the resorts we're hoping yeah
yeah Trump launches a verbal attack on
st. Kitts and you know it's a way of
healing the wounds yeah yeah I have to
go stay at a five-star resort and spa I
don't know there's I mean the list is
endless of places where we'd like to go
what is true is we put so much focus
into making these and and as you can see
right now in this digital age it doesn't
end with putting the show up on TBS at
10:00 a lot of you are gonna see it
online and we hope you see it so we're
still committed to this Mexico show and
making sure that it's seen and that the
message gets across that how lovely and
and talented and vivacious these people
are and how incredible their culture is
that's what we want we think about that
so much that we don't even get a chance
to think about what's the next place
that we're going but we also love
suggestions those suggestions are good
and you guys might have an idea that we
haven't we're not thinking of that would
be perfect so feel free to let us know
if there's a place you think we should
go absolutely and I think but we'll just
an end on this question kind of for
everybody we need Oh from YouTube asks
was there anything in particular for the
Mexican culture that you actually didn't
expect and what did you what really
surprised you would you love the most
yeah I mean I I I felt like as we're
talking to Mexicans about Trump and
about the wall what I the sense I got
for a lot of them they were like yeah
we've been dealing with not either not
you know agreeing with our president
or having issues with our government for
a long time and so they were very
authentic to us in that sense it was
right yeah I think they don't really
like their they don't like some current
president ya know what Trump I don't but
yeah I mean and so for me that that
really came across where they thought
yeah we have complicated politics too
and we're very used to this feeling of
you know of there being political
turmoil so we understand that I mean we
can separate Americans from the policies
of their government right what's
interesting what they were so
appreciative of the fact that we came
and that was really moving to all of us
I think but our fixer and she was
everything for us was kind of done the
show without maritza carbajal and she
said that she never gets moved but she
was brought to tears by the end of it
all because of what it meant to work
there was an immediate understanding of
what it is we were trying to do and then
the Mexican people made it happen so
that's you know they said it takes two
to tango you need it's there's our
effort and I'm not putting our effort
down but it was the chemistry of us
going down there and then the Mexican
people are the ones that that took our
effort and like slam dunked it yes
enthusiasm and graciousness and
incredibly there's such good humor and
goodwill and like I said they were
terrific improv partners and they really
made the show special and that was the
goal from day one which is make them the
star you know and I'll happily be the
bungling clown but the the emphasis
should be on them and I thought the
gasps Diego Luna and present Vicente Fox
were we're different their approaches
but they they were terrific
guess and funny but also really eloquent
about how the Mexican people feel and I
you could feel it in the studio audience
the studio audience was so so gratifying
for them to have these people who are
respected and known speak up on their
behalf and represent Mexico accurately
that that feeling I think charged the
whole trip and made it a special kind of
happening I was impressed by all the
strangers we talked to and then all the
people in the studio that were new the
project and we're helping us across the
board incredibly warm and friendly and
and kind of just full of love and all I
want to do is go back home even back a
couple of days and I went over to CNN
the other day and to take the thing with
Jake Tapper via satellite to promote
this show and that I think aired
yesterday and Mexican people were coming
out while I was just walking from my car
into CNN oh my god they were talking
about how oh my god the the clip you
know about the wall and this and that
and that's the part that gets me the
most excited at this point is making
friends and connections with people you
know there's plenty of people in America
who have whether grown up with me and we
really love our fans and we put a lot of
work into this and we appreciate them I
totally get it if there are other people
that like oh my god he's been on since I
was a kid I'm sick of that guy no I
would understand that it's really nice
to connect with these people who I
wouldn't have connected with otherwise
and I just have these great
conversations that's what I'm looking
forward to now as I live in Los Angeles
so you know I'm looking forward to
Mexicans that live in Los Angeles coming
up to me saying oh man you're the worst
luchador I've ever seen
or your terribly football you know
whatever
yeah those shorts man way too high I'm
looking in the quinceanera
I had one you know that's weird you're a
man I'm just looking forward to that
that's the part that this oral level
feels great absolutely absolutely and
again the reddit AMA you did yesterday
it was very cool to see the the uprising
of supporting people coming out of the
woodwork just to write this huge I love
it oh my gosh they showed me a letter
this morning that someone I don't know
you mail it yeah there's somebody wrote
yeah and just like say what there's a
beautiful letter that's made single in
me in one very short concise letter made
it was a huge boost to all of us I made
it all worthwhile I mean we knew that
already but that was just beautiful
that's great absolutely that that goes
the response we got while we're there
verbally from everyone yeah awesome well
thank you guys I think we're all out of
time thank you for your questions again
you can see the entire color made in
Mexico show team cocoa calm / Mexico
along with tons of behind-the-scenes
footage outtakes oh and also this is a
quick throw in there that's dog bites
I'm not being told to say this but go to
Mexico City yes they have I think more
museums they have something like six
hundred and some-odd museums the food
the food is absolutely insane the
culture the people I just going there
and making the show made me want to take
my family go back and and really get
into that free to come you see it is an
absolutely fantastic destination for
like if you've got a week or even if
you've got a couple of days get there
yeah it's very close also thank you guys
for joining us and we will see you soon
bye everybody bye